this is a segment where we brought
people on they could disagree with us we
do this on instagram every now and then
and she came on with her disagreement so
i was listening also just keep in mind
regardless of what happens in this video
be sure to watch towards the end because
there's a really cool turnaround just
listen
so i want i disagree with uh your guys's
video the other day
about the uh vogue lady that got fired
for like past racist comments okay so
just a bit of context for this um she's
referring to a video where we talked
about a
uh editor for teen vogue who got
cancelled for comments that she made 10
years ago
and you guys basically said that
people shouldn't be held accountable for
what they see in the past
and i disagree with that because
people should be held accountable
because how do you know that you
you have changed behavior if you just
don't apologize
you know what i mean so an apology is an
indication of changed behavior
no it's not so the thing is not about
people being held accountable the issue
is like
her definition of holding someone
accountable is making them apologize in
public
and i think that's what i took issue
with it's too late to apologize
i had to to me it's it's the opposite
a change behavior is the indication of
an apology
not an apology okay you apologized good
what next i almost don't care about the
apology i want you to change your
behavior
i believe more in action than just words
you know but if you change your behavior
then at least
you're not repeating the same actions so
i don't think the issue is like holding
people accountable for past behaviors
i think it's all context there's a
difference between you making an
off-color joke ten years ago that may be
inappropriate today and then you're
doing a criminal act 10 years ago
right like there are levels this stuff
so i think it is more nuanced than that
i would never say
we shouldn't hold people accountable for
things that they've done in the past uh
no that's not that's so the teen vogue
editor
in question i think made an off-color
joke or used a slur
in a tweet like ten or eight years ago i
think that's a bit different in my
opinion
what do you think about that that's what
i want to know and that's where i think
context comes in
who who are they apologizing to um
i feel like society apologize to society
what does that even mean okay so
yeah i feel like they should uh
apologize to society because
i'm not offended i'm not offended so i
don't want them to apologize
what do you mean you're not offended
well let's say someone makes a comment
and i'm not offended by it why should
they apologize to me
okay maybe not apologize to society as a
whole but to um
like the people group that they have
offended because i feel like a lot of
times with these uh celebrities and
influencers
they only apologize after the fact like
after somebody exposes them it's oh i'm
so sorry why
is it is it them being exposed or is it
the fact that maybe they were unaware
and then they learned afterwards
because when we're doing these things on
a platform and in societal white thing
it's kind of interesting
you put up a comment someone calls you
out for it then you apologize because
you got cut
or maybe you didn't know what you did
was wrong and so then you learned
or maybe you forgot maybe you did
something 10 years ago
and you're not going through your
history don't know until someone
points us out you're never gonna i have
a hard time remembering what i did five
minutes ago
so now remember and go back to what i
did and what i
said ten years and in the span of ten
years people change
two years so much that sometimes you
in 10 years people wouldn't even believe
that they said
such things until they oh [ __ ] i
actually wrote that it's a letter it's
my handwriting
and me signing and i can't believe i
wrote that you know that we recently
moved right and there was hope
like there was old stuff that i had with
me and all
old letters that we reread and i was
like wow
corny can't believe i wrote that just
even when you write you go in your
facebook history
and you watch certain messages or
statuses that you made
two three years ago you're like ugh
cringe
you cringe at your own stuff but when
you wrote it
you didn't cringe you just wrote it yeah
and then you even some of you even like
your own
your own statuses and stuff like that
you don't even know that so yeah
you forgot definitely the forget thing
the forget part of it
yeah definitely you forget what you did
but we're more
interested in making people flagellate
and apologize in front of people instead
of just
learning people definitely do have blind
spots but that's why you have
a management team to make sure
that if you said something bad in the
past you can either
delete it so it's not there and people
don't call you out or
and i would respect these people a lot
more if they came out and said hey
i said a lot of [ __ ] when i was younger
that i didn't mean
and i didn't understand this is my truth
i'm owning my truth
rather than only apologizing once they
get caught
why do they need to do that on a public
platform do you have anything you need
to apologize for
we all have things we need to apologize
for okay so what did you do in the past
that you apologize for this is your
chance for you to come forward
and apologize for the bad things that
you've done that you haven't apologized
to everyone for
we haven't found it yet but i know it's
there so i'd like for you to apologize
right now
well obviously i'm not thinking about
something that
why why haven't you looked for it why
haven't you gone through your social
media feed
why haven't you gone through your memory
and and and thought about these things
because if i find out from them and you
haven't apologized for it yet
then you are not really sorry you're
sorry you got caught
no you could just maybe not remember
and that but that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying
i really like the dynamic that's going
on here the way you guys are talking
about it i like it i love it you gotta
commend her for that
okay let's put aside the wonderful point
that you made
okay and take this time to command her
about the way she's having this
conversation
okay it's conversation she's open-minded
i'm not even talking about
what we're talking about anymore i'm
talking about just having a conversation
on things that you disagree
and being able to have a conversation
just the way you have we have to come
and commend her
on just the attitude and the way she's
coming through and exposing her points
this what she's doing right now is the
way
you disagree with someone and there's a
lot of other people that have been doing
that
like that but the way she's doing and
she's thinking okay
she's taking the time to speak she's
taking the time to think
she's taking the time to reflect you
gotta comment that now
wonderful point that you made other than
that
i'm really living the dynamic listen if
you feel like an apology is insincere
fine but also understand it's like a
cash joint too it's like
you should apologize but if you
apologize after i point out your error
then your apology is not sincere
you cannot you can't win then and we all
have things yeah we all have things
it's not even a question of winning it's
a question of you can never be genuine
because no matter what you say you're
not going to be genuine oh yeah you
should apologize you didn't apologize so
you're not genuine all right i apologize
well you're just sorry you got caught
you can never there's the people that
apologize
and they actually mean it yeah it's
tough it's tough because
i'm not saying that apologies don't have
their place i just find it really creepy
just need to apologize to the public the
public
you know you know i mean like who is it
just some faceless mob on twitter and
it's also one of those things where it's
like maybe i just need to have some time
to learn and not be on this public
platform talking about this topic
rather than we demand an apology what
good is an apology it seems we're more
obsessed with
making people pay than we are with
helping people learn
you understand i think people demand
apologies because they're a good
distraction from the very
difficult conversations that need to be
had
it's a lot easier to get someone to say
they're sorry and then you feel like you
got a culprit and somebody
it's like sometimes people just want to
arrest a criminal and then put it behind
bars they don't want to deal with any of
the systemic issues that lead to
specific sense of crimes being relevant
in the area right because that's a much
more
hard issue to deal with you could deal
with sorry
he said he was sorry he paid the crime
right it's like pewdiepie you know
he apologized for what happened in new
zealand but it's like
he didn't do anything to contribute to
that but people were lobbying so much
blame at him and somebody would
people were coming from him because it
was such a a tragic thing that happened
we didn't want to deal with what was
happening at hand so we focus our
attention at the wrong things
because it's a lot harder to talk about
mental health it's a lot harder to talk
about
to talk about a lot of the other issues
the moving parts that may lead to that
so it's easier to put a face on it a big
name on it and make them say sorry it's
a lot easier
i would just say again instead of
smoking so much of the apology let's
talk about the learning you know what i
mean let's talk about
what are the root causes of some of
these issues how do we fix them
where do we go and i think on a personal
level if you've got some apologies you
need to make then go make them but
i'm just not a fan of public apology i
don't i don't think it's the way forward
and i think
they're a distraction that's my my
thoughts on that and that's why i kind
of lose the plot a little bit
because apologies don't do much i think
if you want to make amends
there's some learning that you may have
to do take that time but it doesn't
always have to happen on a public
platform either
people think if you haven't donated a
hundred thousand dollars to
blm or to this organization then it
doesn't matter i don't like the dynamic
if you go by this dynamic that if you
said something in the past you have to
apologize well
everyone can go through that process do
you have said something inappropriate
maybe it wasn't even online maybe you
said it to somebody in person you should
still apologize online
because guess what if we looked at a
celebrity and they made an off-color
remark to somebody in person they would
have to apologize online
definitely so we should hold everyone to
that same standard do we really want to
do that
make everyone start apologizing online
for things that they've
done in the past are we really going to
do that so especially
we know that we all did something that
was you know yeah
it's fun to have these conversations
it's fine too if you want to point out
some behavior
go ahead do your thing but i don't like
this idea of like
let's make them pay i'm not with that so
that was more so my point and i'm like
well
you said you've done something wrong
apologize now
if you are a celebrity you
have the resources you have the
resources
to be able to rectify services yes yes
you have the resources to go and scrub
your past
so nobody can find it yeah yeah so
basically
basically guys don't hide the bad [ __ ]
that you may have said 10 years ago not
it's it's not about hiding it it's about
just
it's about being honest that's what i
think listen you know what we all have
the resources
we all have the resources you can call
your friends you can call your high
school friends
you can go through your social media
feed right now okay because you've got
enough time to come to talk to me on
this live
so you can comb through your posts in
fact you could go through all your
emails
you can call everyone you've ever lived
with and ask them
have i ever said anything that offended
you and you could come back on this live
and apologize to everyone
because i feel like you've done a
terrible thing and you're not ready to
apologize for it
and it's time for you to come forth
because if i find out before you do
then i know your apology apology's fake
no no no no no it's
i didn't say their apology is fake i
said their apology holds more weight
if they're honest about it i just said
that it holds more weight
somebody evolved and what you're
witnessing is their evolution
and try to go back in time for old post
because you're consuming the post in
real time
so you're not actually consuming it as
if it happened 15 years ago you want to
know why i know
because if i slapped you 15 years ago on
your thigh you're not going to feel the
pain
in 2021 all right you're going to right
you're not going to feel it but when it
comes to words because we're reading it
in real time we're getting re-offended
by things that have happened way before
it is not good for our brains and it's
not good for social discourse
we have to accept the fact that people
can go from point a
to point b and that there can be a bit
of a change that's all i wanted to say
on the top but i appreciate you coming
on this give this agreement
let me just end this real quick um i
definitely came up
and i was just like oh i'm gonna get him
um but
you guys have actually changed my
thinking so um i appreciate this
conversation
um it was definitely eye-opening and
uh yeah thank you for your time and
here's the thing right i'll just say
this as a last note to you
understand no ill will i might be a
little bit aggressive sometimes when i'm
chatting but like
you want to grab a beer later we can
definitely grab a beer you know what i
mean
people are being so mean in their
comments don't listen don't listen to
them
don't listen to them because i'm talking
to you right and this is between me this
is what i mean when i say
followers and all this stuff doesn't
matter i'm talking to you with someone
uh
who you know you came on here and you
show your face and you i'm being very
respectful
there's no heart will i disagree with
the idea because i think it's a bad idea
but it's okay for us to disagree
and i hold no ill will towards you know
what i say any terrible things okay
okay thank you so much thank you thank
you for coming on but like i said
internet's a cruel place so don't let it
get to you
it is okay thank you thank you for
coming on
she didn't apologize before she left for
what she's done in the past but it's all
good
uh this is good i was a little bit petty
there
i was like yeah yeah i was waiting for
the petty part yeah of course you have
to be petty
[ __ ] yeah internet can be unforgiving
it's crazy because sometimes when
i'm looking at their lives i'm like yo
what is wrong with you people but it's
always
the ones that are the loudest that we
hear and the ones that we like
we take attention to you can't be like
yeah if they're
if they're followers it's like that
they're all like that that's just dumb
no that's a dumb way to thinking but we
went over that if you want to see the
full live
when we do this disagreement sessions i
normally post them on our patreon
as well as a lot of other bonus content
you can check it out there it was an
interesting discussion she brought some
good points
and it was a tough one because it's not
a yes or no answer
when should you apologize like i've
spoken with creators offline quite a few
times
some of them we'd have that conversation
some of them i apologize to them because
it was like
you know what and if i said something in
public about someone i'll apologize in
that scenario as well
for example dojiket dojo your
apology needs to be as loud as your
disrespect agreed
we did a video about doja we said some
things
and we were wrong and she came out and
she came out
at us the reason why we apologize
publicly
is because those claim we made public
and she came at us publicly and said
that we were wrong
therefore our apology has to be as big
as our disrespect
one other thing is also it was recent
it's a little bit different
right if i had made a joke 10 years ago
and some people found it inappropriate
today
sorry i'm not apologizing for that on a
public platform that's ridiculous to me
okay we also have to admit that like
just because times have evolved
doesn't mean that the past footage has
evolved as well it's still stuck in that
time period
so what you can do that's why people go
back and watch eddie murphy's stuff and
they're like
at the time everyone spoke like that
does that mean they all have to come out
today and apologize
if they want to choose to do so of their
own volition that's fine but we also
have to accept that the world is very
coercive nowadays
when it comes to apologies we don't ask
for them we demand them and then we
threaten people and then we come at them
with all this vitriol
so there has to be a better way that we
go about these things
and also ask yourself why do we care so
much about apologies
and the worst part is even when those
people apologize for the things that
they did in the past
when we when the apology is delivered
nothing happens they're not redeemed
if the people are not satisfied with the
apology they want something more they
want blood
kevin hart this this and that that that
now he's gonna hold the oscars
and then kevin hart was not apologizing
and he even said
if you want to cancel me and being able
to do it and then he apologized
and people even came at his neck he even
had to apologize
twice for something he already
apologized for
now even with the apologies delivered
people were not happy
so i mean they weren't just not happy
they went looking for other things
to discredit the apology because they're
like well you didn't apologize for this
and you didn't apologize for that that's
just like if you watch that joke
in that era at that time most people
don't even see anything wrong with it
you know some things just don't evolve
very well and they and as the times
change you recognize those views change
but it's just like
it's crazy to me it's like yeah when you
were 17 you use the n-word you're now a
30-year-old and you need to apologize
what why you know what i'm saying like i
just don't know how this kind of stuff
is good
it seems we're more concerned with
making people pay than we are with
making people learn
no i mean i just don't like the idea
that people are like on this platform
they're making country music
and someone pulls up a tweet from 10
years ago and everyone's like prove to
us that you changed
what good is that what what good is that
you know especially coming from a
minority background i think it's very
dangerous to go down this road
because a lot of our young brothers and
sisters have done terrible things when
they were younger
especially from poor neighborhoods do we
really want to start going through
everyone's closet and make them
self-flagellate on television
different it's different for everybody
else who don't
have a platform that's what i'm saying
but we're people we're people
what do you think about that point do
you feel like for people who are on a
platform
they need to apologize publicly but
regular folks don't
no and like why is that different well
you got all this
people people people see what we're
doing and having a platform as a
privilege
but yeah it was given to you it is given
to you it's not everybody that has that
privilege yeah but it's not everybody
that chose to do that
it's not everybody that does the thing
that they see what we're doing in the
platform that we have
see right now they're looking at it like
with million whatever
followers or people that have more brand
path they see that and they're like well
you have a privilege you have
all these people watching you all these
people looking at you
that's the privilege that you have you
have that influence you have a power
that nobody has
yeah but it was not just given to me
also
i work for that thing and there's a i
have the privileges
but i also have the downside there's a
lot of sacrifices that i made
to have that so it's really a choice
that i had as well as
you know it's a privilege but it's a
choice that i had not that being said
we're people at the end of the day at
the end of the day we're people and
who is to judge what makes a difference
so because for you i make a difference
because i got a million followers
but a regular joe that doesn't have a
lot of followers
can make something bad as an old fam and
own family
but have an influence in his own family
should he apologize
well to his whole family not necessarily
like who's gonna be the one that's gonna
be judging who's
who's going to be where do we start
where do we start and when do we stop
who needs to apologize for what
according to what they have to me
it doesn't really make sense that we
have to do that because we're
celebrities or whatever you want to call
it to who
who decides who gets to decide that who
gets to decide all that we do which is
at the end of the day i'm a regular joe
that does regular things that happen to
have that
i think if it has nothing to do with
your job you don't have to do the
apology in public
it's me personally if i take an oath you
know to do something
and i serve the people and i violate
that oh that's one thing
if i correct jokes but you know it turns
out that seven years ago i stole some
artwork or whatever okay
actually you know what let's see seven
years ago
i was involved in a hit and run okay
hypothetical
all right and i went to jail then my
time came out i don't have to apologize
to you guys
that's between me and the offending
parties i did my time that's none of
your business
if i said some off-color remark to
somebody 90 years ago
that has nothing to do with you know my
job as a comedian that's between me and
that person
now if i'm a defender of free speech and
then i advocate for canceling someone in
private
now we have a discussion in public
because what i'm saying in private
completely contradicts what i'm
portraying in public
right if i say ladies you deserve the
best and da da da
then i start cheating on my wife left
right and center even though i've been
making fun of guys who cheat
now we have a conversation about what
you've been doing in private because it
directly conflates with what you got
going on public
but otherwise making people i don't
think it's a good thing you know
i don't think it's a good thing and i
think it sends the wrong message it says
the idea that like
based off your follower account the
rules of morality are different
yeah right if you've got a hundred
thousand followers
you're a bad person if you don't
apologize in public but for the guy who
does the exact same thing or something
worse with only 100 followers
he doesn't have to make a public apology
what does that really say about our
value system you know what i'm saying
so that's just my thoughts on on that
last point it really comes down to
people putting people on pez is so it's
not even about the apology it's not even
about oh that person is known and has a
platform he should apologize
it's because you put him on a pla on a
pedestal i want to feel like that person
is a good person because
if you're doing that you have to be a
forgetting that we're humans
to be on that pedestal you have to be a
great human being and you have to
apologize to
everybody because you're on that
pedestal looking down
on us business no don't put people on
pedestals like that that's pretty much
it
well that's it for today's video did you
guys enjoy it please
[Music]
ah
oh
[Music]
you